depuis le 1er janvier les sociétés en
bourse e régis par la loi canadienne sur
les sociétés par actions sont tenus de
fournir aux actionnaires des
renseignements sur leur politique en
matière de diversité au sein du conseil
d'administration comme dans la direction
des renseignements sur la présence des
femmes des autochtones des minorités
visibles et des personnes ayant une
incapacité olga farman et est associée
directrice du bureau de québec chez
fulbright padam farman bonsoir l'ensam
sefilian quelle est donc la nature des
modifications des mesures qui ont été
annoncées
alors ces mesures sont quant à moi
plutôt essentielle puisqu'elle vient
d'imposer une obligation d'information
l'information aux sociétés qui sont
régis par la loi sur les sociétés
canadiennes par action une loi fédérale
nos sociétés vont désormais avoir
l'obligation de dénoncer les mesures
qu'elles ont mis en place mais aussi des
informations quant à la composition de
leur conseil d'administration et de la
haute direction en termes de diversité
et donc quel est l'objectif c'est un
objectif qui est qui est assez
fondamentale et le canada innove
alors c'est un objectif de diversité
c'est un objectif d'information
informations pour les investisseurs qui
vont avoir accès à une information pour
soutenir leurs décisions d'appui ou pas
auprès de ces sociétés aussi
un objectif pour permettre aux membres
issus de la diversité donc comme vous le
mentionnez on parle des femmes des
membres issus des communautés
autochtones communautés ethniques et
aussi des personnes handicapées à
prendre leur place à croître dans
l'organisation et
assumer des fonctions tant au niveau du
conseil d'administration que la haute
direction générale parce que quand on
regarde les chiffres de près on voit que
les femmes représentent à peu près la
moitié de la main d'oeuvre au pays
mais à peine le quart des
administratrices ans des membres des
conseils de monstration et les minorités
visibles ces 12 % des postes de
direction donc ça
l'évolution la place des femmes qui des
membres de la diversité quand même très
lentes
elle est très lent des on observe peu de
mouvement et je vous avoue depuis cinq
ans il ya différentes mesures à être
mises en place par les gouvernements
mais nos organisations les sociétés
publiques puis je vous parle aussi des
sociétés d'état et même nos pme
québécoises doivent à être plus
proactive et doivent dénoncer les
mesures qu'elles mettent en place pour
soutenir l'accès aux femmes
on parle souvent d'un plafond de verre
vous en avez discuté avec plusieurs de
vos invités on parle désormais
maintenant dans le milieu des échelons
casse et des mesures qui font en sorte
que nos jeunes femmes et les gens issus
de la diversité n'accepte pas dès le
départ aux différentes fonctions ou aux
différents postes qui leur permettront
de croître dans les sociétés donc on
parle d'informations de renseignement de
transparence mais on parle pas
d'obligation en même temps vous avez
bien raison alors le canada après de
nombreux débats a pris la position non
pas d'imposer des quotas quotas qu'on
observe notamment en norvège et dans
différents un pays européen mais plutôt
d'y aller avec une obligation de
dénonciation très volontaire ou de
justification donc dans la mesure où une
entreprise décide de ne pas dénoncer les
informations propres à ces statistiques
par exemple au propre aux mesures
qu'elle a mis en place elle devra
justifier dans le cas auprès de ses
investisseurs de ses actionnaires lire
16 ans qui motive sa décision de ne pas
aller de l'avant pour soutenir la
diversité du moins de les écouter c'est
sûr qu'il ya des doutes parfois dans le
marché à cet égard on voit aussi les
limitations des politiques menant à
l'imposition de quotas
ce que le gouvernement fédéral a pris
comme engagement c'est une réévaluation
des mesures et surtout des résultats
observés en 20 25
à ce moment là il va être intéressant de
noter si le gouvernement fédéral va
décider soit de se retourner vers la
fameuse notion de quotas est posée aux
soit carrément des sanctions des
sanctions aux organisations qui
respecterait pas des objectifs précis
comment faire en sorte que ces mesures
entraînent véritablement des résultats
dans les entreprises comment comment les
entreprises doivent faire pour que ça
s'améliore avant tout je crois que c'est
une question de valeurs ça doit faire
partie des valeurs de l'organisation de
soutenir la diversité pour créer de la
richesse parce qu on est dans un
contexte aussi de productivité et de
rayonnement des organisations et du
canada sur la scène internationale mais
par ailleurs une fois que ça fait partie
de l'adn de l'organisation il doit y
avoir des mesures concrètes que toute
organisation qu'elle soit régie par les
dispositions de la loi sur les sociétés
canadiennes par action pas peuvent
implanter on parle de programme de
mentorat on parle d'accompagnement des
membres de la diversité on parle aussi
de formation formation sur les billets
est conscient parce qu'il y en a il y en
a par rapport aux femmes
il y en a par rapport aux membres des
diverses communautés alors vous avez
toute une série de mesures et
d'accompagnement pour ouvrir le dialogue
je vous donne l'exemple aussi
les horaires de travail plus flexible on
sait que les femmes et surtout les gens
même la nouvelle génération ont
revendiqué ont besoin de davantage de
flexibilité et on voit aussi des mesures
et des formations par des mouvements
comme les faits a par exemple où là on
évite les jeunes femmes des différentes
entreprises à assumer à parler
d'ambition et à rejoindre un mouvement
je parle d'un mouvement québécois bien
sûr là dessus et là c'est une nouvelle
mesure c'est pour des entreprises cotées
en bourse n'est ce pas combien
d'entreprises sont visés alors on parle
de 600 entreprises qui seraient
désormais à visée depuis le 1er janvier
20 20 ouais
et est ce que les autres entreprises qui
ne sont pas en bourse sont également
visés non c'est un bon point à lorsque
le gouvernement espère et aliments brrr
les observateurs du milieu c'est que ce
genre de mesure ce genre d'obligations
vont inciter davantage de pme de
sociétés à suivre la cadence à mettre en
place des mesures et à propager
l'information pour faire la promotion de
la diversité
olga farman c'est très intéressant
important surtout merci c'est moi qui
vous remercie monsieur fillion bonne
soirée au revoir au revoir